proposers the fight is back and the
stakes are higher than ever because a
hundred percent of 50 percent of the
population is at risk of total
eradication of their identity I'm
talking about men and overwhelming six
states now have female governors which
means only 44 states stand between us
and a complete Empire it's time to suit
up for battle because wardrobe please
there's a war on med something ominous
is happening to men in America a war on
men
the Liberals war on men is working
med this war is nothing new
women have been out to get us from birth
in fact all fetuses start as female in
the womb and tell some of us brave souls
fight our way to a penis and what's
worse just because women's bodies are
tiny baby apartments they think they get
to call the shots on motherhood
battleground 1 babies
senator Tammy Duckworth recently became
the first senator to give birth while in
office and then something even more
frightening happened Tammy Duckworth
arrived to cast a vote with her 10 day
old daughter by her side IV Senate
unanimously decided last night to allow
working moms on the hill to bring their
newborns to work like anything else in
the Senate though it wasn't without some
belly aching senator Orrin Hatch even
asking and telling the AP but what if
there are 10 babies on the Senate floor
exactly hatch knows babies are loud
disruptive and in diapers and that's
totally his thing sure there's only one
female senator under 50 but women are
sneaky they're always creeping up behind
you to say it's yours
don't be fooled this newborn fever is
just the latest way women have stripped
men of their basic liberties did you
know that as recently as 2009 the Senate
used to have a men's only pool of course
they did where else was Mitch McConnell
supposed to birth his eggs and in 2013 a
record number of women invaded the
Senate and that suddenly months later
the Senate floor bathrooms had to be
expanded for women these women are
capturing our porcelain Thrones women
just want everything men have our money
our power our convenient bowel movements
this is a pissing contest that we will
win because we do it standing and that's
not all men are being attacked on all
fronts our homes our works even our
happy places specifically the happiest
place on earth
battleground number two Disney World the
Pirates of the Caribbean ride is ground
zero for the feminist assault where cry
babies are saying outrageous things like
auctioning off Brides at a family theme
park is problematic this attraction the
Pirates of the Caribbean it's being
under 50 years it was originally a bride
auction they've decided that this is too
controversial and it's a me-too moment
maybe the little hula girls at this
small world they need to come out as
well stuck on that ride it's a small
world I was stuck in there for like 45
minutes of course laura ingraham got
stuck on this small world ride because
every hero has an origin story you know
what getting trapped in a globalist
hellscape of multicultural animatronics
is loris now the removal of the wench
auction from the Pirates of the
Caribbean right sets a dangerous
precedent to men because it's different
Disney and its rides teach boys to
become men if little boys can't look at
a bunch of seafaring murder pimps and
think that's what I want to be when I
grow up what do they have left
representation matters and look I know
I'm right here
because the men who are upset by this
change are the most well-adjusted people
in America adults who go to Disney World
but man magic isn't the only ground
we've lost in the war on men
they're also renovating the fields of
math and science which brings me to our
final battleground stem it stands for
science technology engineering and math
though it might as well stand for
stealing to eliminate men because women
are taking our math and science jobs for
years I thought it was because we
summoned women on our calculators but
turns out there's another reason the
Scully effect women who regularly watch
or watch the x-files are 50% more likely
to work in science technology
engineering or math compared to women
who haven't been fans nearly two-thirds
of women in those fields say agent
Scully served as a role model for them
how dare they math is our thing
two-thirds of these women said Scully
was a role model but what about the
other half because of the X x-files a
whole generation of women are storming
our labs and taking our jobs and if this
show inspired them who knows what other
strong female characters have activated
women there might be a horde of warrior
princesses out there ready to attack or
an army of women just waiting to explain
it all it's unbelievable men are the
ones who explain things explaining
things to people is the last thing men
have left ok ok let me explain it to you
you say opposers men we are under attack
we need to make Disney less family and
more manly because we've lost the Battle
of Space Mountain
but we need to counter strike until
Disney's Epcot Center has two balls as
God intended
and we need to get back to the position
where the only time a man has to deal
with an infant at work is when he's
delivering it with his right hand and
holding a lit cigarette in his left men
get in your battle stance which takes up
approximately three seats on the subway
we're going to compensate for the ground
we've lost in fact we'll overcompensate
until we feel secure again
[Music]